jodhpur india is a sea of blue in the  middle of a hot dry desert  welcome to the blue city  jodhpur is the second largest city in  india's rajasthan province  surrounded by a wall with bastions the  striking blue buildings in jodhpur  contrast sharply and beautifully with  the neighboring tar desert  it's the older quarters built in 1459  where many of the blue buildings are  found  some say the color is associated closely  with the brahmins india's priestly cast  and the blue houses of the old city  belong to families of that cast  there's also an argument that termites  are the real reason  builders added copper sulfate to the  whitewash to thwart the pests which  resulted in the eye soothing blue  however locals say the blue is a natural  indigo dye  a final explanation might be the city's  nickname it's known as the sun city  and the blue helps keep the homes cool  either way jodhpur looks like a real  life fairytale  you